breaking news the united states just
publicly stated that they want to be the
global leader in bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies this is absolutely a
game changer what am i talking about the
united states this morning put forward
an executive order from the president
biden administration and under that
executive order there's a very specific
piece that i want you to pay attention
to here it says that they want to
promote u.s leadership in technology and
economic competitiveness to reinforce
u.s leadership in the global financial
system they want to direct the
department of commerce to work across
the us government in establishing a
framework to drive u.s competitiveness
and leadership in leveraging digital
asset technologies this framework will
serve as a foundation for agencies and
integrate this as a priority into their
policy research and development and
operational approaches to digital assets
now this one section isn't the only
place where they're actually saying this
we also have this quote right out of the
executive order that says the united
states must maintain technological
leadership in this rapidly growing space
supporting innovation while mitigating
the risks for consumers businesses the
broader financial system and the climate
that doesn't exactly sound to me like
the united states and the white house
wants to sit out this competition it
sounds a lot like the united states of
white house wants to be the leader in
this fast-growing innovative industry
there's a lot of people over the years
who have thought that the u.s government
wasn't paying attention or that they
actually may be abrasive to the industry
but that's not what's happening the
united states government just publicly
stated they want to be the leader they
want to be number one if anyone's gonna
benefit from bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies the united states wants
to be the biggest winner this is kicking
off a global competition make no mistake
about it every single country across the
world is now competing who will be the
leader who will get the hash rate on
proof of work blockchains like bitcoin
who will actually get the investors who
will get the companies who will get the
jobs who will get the innovation and who
will get the economic prosperity the
global competition is underway and the
united states is not sitting on the
sidelines they're in the game and they
want to be the leader this is bullish
for bitcoin this is bullish for
cryptocurrencies this is bullish for
america and ultimately the winner in a
global competition among all these
nation states is going to be the
individual citizens competition leads to
innovation and innovation is exactly
what the people want hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time